what if as soon as the strikes end they
are then able to announce the new
Stargate franchise and oh by the way in
a couple of months the animated movie
comes out
but could they actually keep an animated
movie like that secret this long
they did it with the Babylon 5 Road home
movie we knew nothing about that until
it was complete it was done it was in
the can it was ready to be released JMS
announced it J Michael zaginski the
creator of Babylon 5 announced it on
Twitter
nobody knew nobody had that
they were able to keep it really really
secret because it's a bunch of animators
locked in a room and the actors only
come in and then again get locked in a
room for a couple of days